I was told not to shake your hand
because your hands broke yeah the right
hands broken right but I use it as a
sledgehammer so I'm okay with it
yeah yeah my god I mean first of all I
just have to ask you I know this sounds
like I'm obsessed with myself a big
surprise how soon after you won this
match did you think about the Conan
curse immediately
did you really immediately when I got to
the back the UFC PR came over and he
said great job thing is gonna get crazy
I said nothing's crazier than the fact
that I just won this fight even though I
went to Coney other people had warned
you don't do Conan show isn't that right
yet he said don't do it yeah I mean the
fans were they the betting line I was
like a minus 160 right underdog right
the day after I left here I was up at
240 yeah close to four it was crazy
yeah yeah like everybody bet their money
on Stevie right right we've broken it
now we thank ya we thank you for that
something crazy happened I want to bring
up as soon as you won Saturday you saw
your next opponent yes I did he was
outside the Rings we're in a suit and
Brock Lesnar Brock Lesnar and you said
you called him out yes you started
calling him out he comes into the ring
right so we don't and he threw you down
Brock Lesnar just may be the strongest
human being walk in the face of God's
earth and he's your next fight he's
gonna be the next guy I fight he's six
for 300 Lesnar right now is the WWE
Heavyweight Champion right a former UFC
champion a guy I've known for a long
time and as I saw him through the cage I
was getting ready to fight and I usually
go out second I went out first this time
because I was challenging I was standing
there trying not to look at Brock and I
was like what's he doing here then when
I saw him come in he came in the in the
cage and he was wearing this suit and
for some reason he had the bottom of his
suit pants tucked into cowboy boots it
was the weirdest visual I used to see I
rock that's the look I had all through
the 80s
I don't know what Brock was doing yeah
so it's six five three hundred pounds
he's got his pants tucked into his boots
and he comes over he throws me and he
told me across the Octagon and I told
him Brock you get to push me now but
when we fight you get to go to sleep in
the Octagon so I'm gonna put a missing
here's the question here's the million
dollar question will you come back on
this show just before you fight it let
me tell you something there is never
going to be a time where I don't beg to
come on this show before I fight
[Applause]
you